Now let's look at the next step in converting light to data.
The actual sensor information, with Bayer data, will have something like this.
We saw some of that in the previous slide.
The red is chunked up into small reds here, because that's the red rows.
The green, of course, also have this Bayer pattern.
This is, again, output of a Bayer filter.
We want to demosaic this to get our real image.
Going through the process that I talked about,
with some interpolation, we can construct an image like this.
Here you see a little bit of an aliasing, because again,
we have intentionally showcased the kind of artifacts of doing this.
But simple cleaning and
interpolation that's done, this image would be made to look perfect.